were so full podcast welcome to the one
so full podcast today is was so full
podcast day for everybody out there who
listens every Friday
thank you very much for listening today
I'm going solo fool
I'm going solo Rodrigo Torres is in
Mexico City hanging out over there
eating some good tacos it's just me
today and the manager over there on the
side and our engineer to the right over
here chillin like a villain
you guys go probably go through a
hundred ever 100 podcast every week oh
my god
how do you do that man but about 100
podcast is time you don't even care I
don't know man I never do that but
people do that man I suppose you have a
ponytail like most people who work
sucked in doing what you do they have a
long ponytail and it's braided thank God
for Silicon Valley who works in the
dungeon I don't know that guy was a
comedian I know that guy he's a funny
comedian he's been around that dude he
played guitar yeah Henry Phillips Henry
Phillips yeah I work with him before the
comedy magic club he's nothing like that
killed and he covers young Wars old fool
okay man
today's episode is sponsored by Dollar
Shave Club shout-out to that guy who got
a Dollar Shave Club for judo not here so
but if you want to be shining like his
fat cheeks go to the Dollar Shave Club
we have a we love having Dollar Shave
Club as our sponsor where jukka Tori
loves it Yemen he even took to a new
razor and dr. Carver shea butter with
him to Mexico right now man he's over
there
shaving commotion go over there Mexico
showing everybody how to shave do you
know why Dollar Shave Club is the
smarter choice it's a great shave at a
great price
conveniently delivered right to your
door like they just bring it to your
door you don't have to go to the store
and get more razors the more cheaper no
more cheap shaves you know it's funny
like I thought I noticed in like towards
the like the late 90s that all the good
razors are locked up in a safe now
really people were stealing razors I
guess meth heads or sell anything comes
with the awesome dr. Carver's shea
butter which helps prevent ingrown hairs
and fight razor palms every time and if
you have a curly beard razor bumps or a
problem and I'll even know sometimes if
that was a bump or a blackhead now
remember I will press on it and press on
it and no hero come out to the next day
I got like this bubble
I saw infected Oh gross
so you want to avoid that problem go get
that Dollar Shave Club you two can make
the smarter choice by joining Dollar
Shave Club as one of the listeners of as
one of our listeners for a limited time
new members can get their first month of
the executive razor with a tube of their
dr. Carver's shea butter for only three
dollars actually five bucks 30 bucks
five bucks with Free Shipping after that
month the Rangers are just a few bucks a
month that's a 15 dollar value for only
5 bucks your first box will arrive and
you'll get an awesome heavy handle razor
or full cassettes of four cartridges and
a tube of their shave butter no hidden
fees no commitments cancel anytime
cancel anytime right to get the deal
join today at Dollar Shave Club calm /
pool Dollar Shave Club / come / fool
that's dollarshaveclub.com / fool so
that's our ad man and we're so happy to
have an ad we're so happy that our show
is doing well you know you can listen to
it on audio boom we're the top 100 nine
last week we were number 75 and before
that we were number 65 with our because
of you guys who listen every week and
support the worst of food podcast so
upcoming shows May 18 to 24
campy improv with Rodrigo Torres
Christian and transit on March and Rizzo
doing the second show on Saturday and
hopefully a Sunday show and our late
shows surprising she'll be there man
looking for a victim jewels first to the
fourth update the Arlington Texas at the
Arlington improv June 25th albeit don't
with your matter where a BNI shows sold
out but even get you excited about it so
loud sometimes man you gotta pay
attention to my post my Instagram my
Twitter cuz shows pop up and then
they're sold out like we haven't we're
having our first show in East Los
Angeles on solo Street and 1st Street at
a place called cities June 25th and that
shows so loud and like in 35 minutes
it was gone man and this guy was selling
ticket out of it house yes man so the
show is sold out but that in East LA
July 1st
abierta ever amphitheater in Tucson
Arizona with Paul Rodriguez Holly oh my
god did you take your time II
with Paul Rodriguez and Tierra Malo
and war ii-era Malo and war Tierra I
remember that bandim you had to know
that bad theater is the from East Los
Angeles I can't remember any other songs
but they used to perform with little
Willie G who we had on our show the Ku
band but the band broke up like in the
90s and they separated and one brother
got into a fight with the other brother
they caught the silence brothers and
they broke into a big fight
so one brother took the half of the band
that way and the other brother took the
other band that way and there was the
era 1 and PSI 2 so I remember that
because college Oscar was on stage and
we were at the Victor Steakhouse in our
ham bro or Monterey Park and he was a
joke about the era one or two and that
fool walked up to him hey man I'm from
theater that [ __ ] was hilarious man it
was funny because you making fun of
their songs he said I'm yeah man I got
all your albums I got the song you guys
did the only one I got the collective
one I'd like to stay in sucker the remix
and I forgot all kinda what it was so
that was that fool that was hilarious
I wish I knew the name of the song
[ __ ] I'll look it up right now
I look so gonna be cool man I'm only
gonna be doing like 20 minutes on stage
not even 20 so we're like the opening up
for the bands it'll be Paul and I so
it'll be a fast show but I do like half
hour each um I might bring some merch I
know the bags I got every merge come I
bring merged
however Gigot sadly I don't know it's
gonna be quick so two centers go now
so yeah man so this is um the other
people you got might have heard their
songs they were clean they were armed
they had a song that was popular for a
while so I pile in here can't find it
I'll go to youtube I'll put it in later
man
but I want you have to hear it right now
so you guys know what's up also check
out the Philippians WorldCom slash tour
for our shows date for the rest of the
year
Dollar Shave Club don't forget
dollarshaveclub.com and also go to our
filipa worldcom our little Amazon window
and search for whatever you need for
your delight so what's up fool man last
week I did a show and Colusa Casino with
Larry bubbles more bubbles Brown and
Rodrigo Torres it was like um thank you
everybody who showed up sold-out show it
was fun
and I haven't been haven't been in a
wild man it was crazy as crowd oh my god
it was crazy first was you know who we
were staying at the hotel room right
next to the casino and I thought that
you know we could just walk through the
casino and get to the show no man they
gave us a ride we run a little golf cart
and they took us to the side and the
green room was like um a block away from
where the show was so we had to UM get
another ride to the from the green room
to the show so we're backstage and I get
introduced the crowd is going crazy
thirty minutes into my show people start
yelling [ __ ] out like really getting
[ __ ] out like trying to be part of the
show and then I was doing a joke about
the 49ers and the Raiders
and this dude was a was a capper
nature's dependent by and once you talk
to me from the stage and this guys
wearing first of all here a big afro
just like kappa game but he's bald from
the front so he wouldn't let that govern
the Three Stooges
Larry fine that's the one that has a big
bushy here
he looks here but he was bald man so I
don't know I want started making fun of
him you know I started using my improv
skills as a little gentleman we have
Kaepernick's father right here and then
after everybody laughed I took a little
Neil and the crowd goes crazy I even
took a selfie with this guy because he
would be so loud that's all fat solo
from the from the left hand side he was
yelling out solo isms which I didn't
know what the hell they were Holloway's
oh what a lame-o I Love You Man you're a
bad day I'll let it take you for coming
out he got all talking about my shows is
um like you go to some shows and people
are [ __ ] dressed up man like don't
wearing the best clothes like you go see
Bruce Bruce or you go see Sergey Taylor
Taylor everybody in the audience is
dressed up like they're about to go up
on stage like it's a fashion show manly
people are dressed up like Mother's Day
and a Baptist Church on a Sunday at my
shows or maybe just to loser man people
showed up in their [ __ ] house shoes
like there's a guy in the front wearing
house shoes with [ __ ] basketball
shorts and a jersey and his girlfriend
was all dressed up I guess somebody
didn't really want to go he's sitting in
the front man house shoes let me tell
you man I'm not gonna pick a fight with
nobody at the club wearing a [ __ ]
house
whose house shoes man so this guy in the
back is wearing like a oversized black
Hanes Jersey it was like um it was long
man I think I'll show went down to
Whitney's I think he was wearing the the
Raiders nightie
what do you call that man what when do
you say to yourself a [ __ ] and go to the
comedy show bro I'm gonna get all
dressed up
Brahma [ __ ] iron my black long
t-shirt E and I'm gonna make sure it
goes down to my knees and I'm aware my
pants bro I'm a little like a like an
Indian woman bro basically what this
could look like so their food was all
dressed up heckling from the back what's
up was gonna email it
what's up fool man we're back yes that
[ __ ] was crazy man
it's when we wanna do it like a theater
show people are drunk
it gets crazy it turns into la my own
show that the wild coyotes like to
perform at the wild coyotes on Monday
and Wednesday night it was like comedy
battle royale man like you really have
to do improv like I know a lot of
comedians they sit down in a riff after
stool but it's a trick man it's trying
to put down anybody who ribs you know if
you could if you could riff you could
riff but it's a same riff every time he
goes up there any letter say rift where
you know he's being heckled and you got
to make something up and then go back to
your set that's real riffing man when
you were you're doing your set then
somebody heckles you with the Kaepernick
Jersey with a bald head or a cholo and
then you're gonna go back to your set
that's real that's a real riffing man we
need to just riff make fun of somebody
and then go back to your act and most of
the time when I'm a
front of somebody so that I've done a
lot of shows I'm doing like the same
joke I did on this person that I didn't
tell you see you know like if I make fun
of somebody with a greasy forehead it's
gonna be the same joke I did the last
week on somebody else was a greasy poor
head I mean could that rift or when I
first said it was so hilarious I had to
put it to my act it oh man and I got to
hang out with so ripping like there's
some people who rip who are really good
like that Rickles but there's some
people who riff who uh I'm not really
making [ __ ] up man you know who you are
Jack you know he like you know riffing
to me man like if you're gonna like
improvise I would I would do that if I'm
trying to do a new material like you
know I go up there just start talking
[ __ ] do something funny comes up you
know what I mean you're man like the
best roofing or improvisation act and
thing I ever done was when he's five
convenient would not be for me and they
were all bombing I mean they were
sucking man like II like the kind of
bonds where you're questioning yourself
why am i what am I out doing comedy on
Friday night when I should be at the
movie theater with my kids or taking my
wife out for dinner or staying home and
writing new jokes the kind of bombing
man when you just want to where nothing
is really good man like you go home and
your wife is [ __ ] uh an open mic or
something bad bombings and I was
laughing in my head like [ __ ] he's
talking guys [ __ ] suck big [ __ ]
suck what am I doing here on Friday
night with these amateurs I go up there
and I started bombing harder than
everybody it's like probably hard and
let the other guys bombed but they got
off the stage in ten minutes I'm gonna
go to him bomb for 30 minutes so I don't
know what to do man the jokes aren't
working
I went through all my material in 15
minutes so I did something that I
learned that you can only learn on your
bombing on stage I started being honest
really honest like I told the audience I
gotta be honest with you guys I was out
there in the back being cocky with
myself like oh geez comedians [ __ ]
suck the first guy sucked his litter I
did I said his joke the way he said it
and then I said this guy's [ __ ] is
sucked fair did the second guy sucked
and I'm back then saying this guy
[ __ ] suck and and I'm up to Tagami
can destroy the audience but look at me
man I'm [ __ ] bombing harder and I'm
set and in the bottom and then this is
how a my improv skills came up right up
right above the stage was a boat okay a
[ __ ] boat like those oh those are a
boat man it was just a goddamn boat and
and asked him man look at me man
normally I'm [ __ ] uncouple under a
boat I'm not a [ __ ] on a sinking ship
I [ __ ] suck before this [ __ ] ship
so I was bombing hard our guest Justin
Wright was some fool watching your TV
yesterday at the [ __ ] Miami podcast no
you weren't getting people it was for
calmly dynamics yeah man I have on
though I have Roku or her Roku of my TV
cuz I got rid of cable right right I got
the same thing yeah so then I will I
looked up for comedy and comedy dynamics
has a
page four cut its new wave spin-off and
I'm Bob summers I get his soldiers his
the special you arrive to cover the
dynamics and now I looked at it you're
you around you're the first comedian of
a young comedy show uh yeah man um
actually that was laughs mobs we got
next
and it's actually you on Spotify and
Napster and it's running it's been over
in South Africa you know I got some
friends over there who told me they um
they saw it on television you know what
it's a good sort of look for me you know
me I like it you know did a great job
oh I like what BT did to me well back in
the day you had horrible and you did the
arm the world by Rhode Island to that
would always pace oh yeah yeah yeah I
did that did they air that I don't know
I'm not the same you you did yeah I do
Eric Eric who was one of the producers
told me that they held back on it for
some reason I don't know but byron man
he's got a lot of good things going on
for himself right now they held back on
it because I think Byron Allen was suing
these other stations that wouldn't put
on his shows hmm right right right right
yeah yeah yeah he'll be loose with
Comcast and he won so their little arrow
there mm-hmm
like gentlemen we have a guest today
that um people say I started doing
stand-up comedy with him no idea started
doing comedy with him back in 1996
oh man jeez I can't wait here eat a
hamburger ha ha ha I went to Italian
restaurant me I was hungry what do you
have it it's a chicken chicken sandwich
chicken sub sandwich with you know all
the good things on what napkin
you know I gotten everybody yeah I
didn't ask them for an app and I was
just so hungry I'd just like to go just
give me next manwich I'm Ontario but I
was good man run a horn for me honey my
wife doesn't cook for me so I gotta
figure it out myself ah daughters grown
she don't she just worry about you know
these teenagers they worry about
themself is big [ __ ] selfish man oh
man am I allowed the cursor mouth
whatever you want all right cool oh ok
there's a gentleman your see Thomas when
I first met this food they were yo Baba
your mama never liked [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah you down I'll see about that
without your upper I was talking with
Lisa I was like [ __ ]
I know this is room for a longer time
and he knows the same fools
I know and I was telling them I first
met your see we manage each other I
think at the natural budge or open mic
at the comedies program big national
[ __ ] that one actual fudge because
that's a [ __ ] classic old-school
natural fudge it was like up up it was a
closet it was that they had like six
chairs in there hot-ass spotlight and an
old freaky lady used to run it she took
a [ __ ] the big out-of-the-way staff oh
yeah I love you if you crush you could
you got a chance to go crush if you know
what I mean oh yeah and she had a
husband named Johnny Johnny Robert I
won't remember him yeah man he wasn't he
jolly Roberts he was a guy with a suti
to host the show and I'm my first time
there man I was like it was late late 94
right late 94 and I wouldn't wanna put
her doing stand-up I don't know [ __ ]
about that oh I just want 80s comic
right I would have to dress like Fozzie
Bear bro I Ducote we still like Fozzie
Bear I had a [ __ ] code with a patchy
fog and I had a bolo tie idiot Wow and
then I go up there and her husband right
Brenda whatever name we yeah
her husband was Johnny Roberts he was
hoping to show head kid
we're shooting a Carroll comedy show
next week
you want to be what you wanted for that
I made it Wow for us I thought I made it
I went back and I kind of got a [ __ ] up
my pants I gotta buy this how many
review was to set later and then good
time they didn't know it's a year later
in local axes yeah look to channel three
you can even have cable to work right
there on fountain near Scientology right
there man you need a have you been past
that place yeah it took what apart we
did it it's an apartment always pointed
I go yeah I started there I think it's
called a Melrose Playhouse
no I mean it looked like an apartment
complex to they don't have anything on
it the last time I drove past there
it was funny Michael Dell eight-by-tens
and now a lot of the people that were
starting out with you a lot of bullying
Jamie Kennedy Center Levine yeah and I'm
the others by a host man all these
photos up and I was I didn't know Alonzo
Bodden but he was staring at them -
there goes who are these people says
those are the stars it was like pictures
of people that never been to that place
ringing some rings and I'm like Rita
Rudner is [ __ ] yeah and we had a wild
coyotes man I'm sure you talk about that
a lot on your shows but while coyotes
was awesome also a ten years later oh
yeah man ago we peel yeah man I remember
man you know just going in just you know
getting my chops up groans you know that
play stuffing my skin man and and I owe
a lot to them those guys bro you know
and it's been some wild [ __ ] going on
over there - man a lot of cholos used to
come through it mongos and I remember
Oscar De La Hoya used to hang out there
- men and it was it was fun times back
then you know and Gabe you shoot man
Chicago don't forget me dad yeah dad
we're drunk a delete Jesus Panthro we
got split a tree Jay I don't know a
bunch a little rod some gay guy named
Ron Williams the white boy with the
white boys named David chase chase yeah
chase chase oh yeah I remember you can
tell in there was a karaoke let that
fool sing it hahaha Jesus man it's good
to see me I'm glad you're having a show
man what is this like heard this is your
one hundred and fiftieth hundred
fiftieth 150 of 151 honey okay like like
Bacardi Rum
well yeah baby bring the black guy in so
right now I was talking about man yeah
well the Roman no there's no room theme
here tonight Jesus try and guess up man
hey Soph ritual do you want to be okay I
was talking about my new show I did a
lot of and there could be that was there
but I was last
you know it was like 20 people there it
was in San Pedro the Sheraton a Friday
night and I watching a food bomb bro the
kind of bar with my what the
[ __ ] doing a night
currently knows our topic okay years ago
and but I'll be cocking the back to go
to my cell yeah but killed him up our
air it was a little wax that's why I'm
getting paid 60 bucks
okay you know they lowered a now and
here is lower down $25 that was business
not even that bag just reach their
people rocky so I walked there man and I
start bombing hard but what I'm learning
from was that that was the first night I
would always on stage and I told the
audience what I was thinking before I
went up I was telling the audience was
in a bar or they put [ __ ] sock yeah
and every time I said that about
somebody they were dying bro some was
think they suck but I thought I want to
kill up here not about bombing
I gotta make fun of these hacks get to
get laughs right right right commands
but I changed it man I learned a lot but
there may be honest it works still went
back to coyotes walk you three honest I
another respect over there yeah we
always tell the audience here that the
people that that wins in that room and
we got better in comedy that audience
got better at heckling to the same
people there right yeah we had a lot of
regulars that came through over there
man and they were raunchy bro
they were raunchy man I'll tell you if
you can break that crowd pro you had
something he really had something you
know and I don't know man it's just I
was just going man because I was happy
to get paid for one I know Neil it was
awesome I will get there early oh you're
there all right pretty good eat man and
uh but it was a man great time came in
some other places man we used to do to
man of course
Rudy's world Rudy's room when was that
the Red Bull Oh the bravenwolf
I mean now you like got me scratching my
head I am another Casa latina - there's
another spot oh man or Tuesday nights
yeah it was Monday night while Coyotes
Tuesday night Casa latina
Wednesday night somebody has some -
Thursday night the Commerce Casino and
Friday night I don't know where ray
Redgrave or somebody
it wasn't Rudi back then though no he
took it over after a while and it was a
man Edwin San Juan is doing good too man
I wouldn't you know he's out in Vegas
doing this thing today Planet Hollywood
and I went out on now work with him a
couple of times man what's that like man
to work seven days a week it's uh it's
awesome for me it's just you know it's
I'm in the gym you know not only that
I'm hanging out with a good friend man
you know all you guys may not consider
my my good friends you know and just to
be out there with him and see his family
and him living in a good light man it
was awesome for me you know um but to
perform every night like that is like
being in a gym and going to work out you
know and he allowed me to do that you
know I wasn't trying to make it tough
for me even he wanted me to make it
tough phone cuz it makes him better you
know he doesn't get comics like us to go
out there and challenge him you know and
you know a couple of times I would do it
for him but he would pull because he's a
back we are veteran me we could follow
each other no problem you know but um
he's uh he's doing well man I'm happy
for him yeah man your origin for New
York
I'm from Jerez Atlantic City I lived in
New York before I came here there was a
lot of people think I'm from the most
beautiful but uh play game are you it's
not on a um Pitney village I'm not on
let me see Baltic Avenue will probably
be my wife said that that are those fish
actually get are the ones that they are
I'll take it again you know what I just
brought that game I did about that game
and it's a new one you know they have
one now with a credit card
oh yeah I guess you know a lot of people
were kind of sending money in the mapa
monopoly money so man I gotta do credit
cards and stuff so now I'm joking please
laughing seriously I'm an AC bro how you
have you performing ever know what's
wrong with you man never been booked got
the door gotta gotta got um they used to
have the trop at something comedy stop
at the Trop but they closed that down
yeah but I thinking that was just the
Borgata man he still common to the air
over here I started comedy here man I'm
back in 93 I uh I had just got out of
prison and I got I know that I know
I don't know you were in prison but but
I I am on my from my peripheral people
talking I think Toby hates or maybe
every Blake had mentioned it yeah he to
score from one of them yeah um I used to
uh not no no Eric Blake yeah yeah no
actually I was I was yeah I was me my
homeboy it's a long story
Eric Blake uh he was I can't put his
business out there like that just will
cut in just another karmic yeah another
cop
but anyway man back in the day I knew
Eric yeah eat the ball right day he was
a baller man but uh back in the day
dough you know that's when I first met
him and but I had decided to get into
comedy sometime later and that's when
Def Jam was out and I was inspired by
that I was like oh I can do that and
then at that time my girl that I was
dating her girlfriends boyfriend was
doing stand-up and I was like yo this
guy is deep he's funny wouldn't saw me
is like funny I'm like y'all imma get my
mind my knowledge from him and I was
like yo Brandon yo man what do I need to
do to start doing stand-up comedy and
I'm waiting for him to give me like the
Holy Grail you know what I mean he's
like just do it
ha ha I'm like come on man there's got
to be more with what else is there man
it's something else I needed I got to do
push-ups oh I need to sit ups or
whatever what what I need to do he's
like just do it bro that's it just go up
on stage and do it and that was it that
was it and I was like let's bewildered
bro like oh man it's got to be more out
there but um I just I wrote out three
minutes man and did my first set over at
the golden sails I don't know if you
know that I love you remember that no no
that was uh I was a el segundo o Segundo
yeah yeah it's called golden sails um
yeah so I went out there man and I had
three minutes I think the guy put me up
first and man I can remember just
already she I must have left a trail of
[ __ ] going towards the stage bro ha ha
ha I was petrified I mean like sweating
and I got up in but I got what I did was
before I went up those I convinced
myself I said look no man
what happens you get through this
material there's three minutes you
worked on as soon as I said like two or
three words boo and it was like it was
like a ripple effect bro he's all black
people okay and they're raunchy they
they didn't give a rat's ass about the
[ __ ] I had to say and I'm like saying in
my mind just get through it get through
it get through and I'm talking and I'm
talking they just kept booing getting
louder and louder man I'm man bro and so
something in the back of my mind said
hey man listen just tell them to calm
down and you know you want to you want
to get this this last thing out just get
him to calm down
and I'm like hey hey hey guys just hey
listen just calm down please just just
calm down a second let me just say one
more thing please just let me say one
more and I noticed that the crowd
started getting lower and lower the
boosters started you know and they all
calmed down it was quiet and I was like
[ __ ] you ha ha ha and left and ever
since then bro
I've been going strong hit on that's
crazy but a black president like you
Michael we had a chapel Huang Garcia
yeah I feel talking about that now man
they were booing me they were booing me
in a song Wow
it was a boo Wow ha ha ha cheese bro
that's the worst oh man but yeah man I
was my first time ever going up man and
I never looked back man and I looked at
but um yes I'm telling you had that one
that one huh but that was your first
time you came back you try to get though
right um yeah man I kept going obviously
I'm still here I'm still doing a booty
like that my first ever pilot may be sad
and I come back for another year hmm but
I've been booth a couple of times after
that time I remember I did a def cam
audition got booted I'm doing that and
then the next day they gave me another
chance at the comedy act theater got
booed over there - sounds like he go
it's ain't working and I definitely got
a job I got a job and I was working and
I said you know I'm dating systems
yeah you remember that about why I was
talking to my wife earlier about it cuz
ROC cuz I'm I will remember that most
things I was thinking like the wait a
minute your C knows house a hmm which we
call we agree to call vicuna growing up
and you know BB he was the [ __ ] big a
bullshitter and Rafa my boy he played
left-hander he to hit long big guy big
Mexican food oh yeah yeah yeah oh I grew
up with a three guys yeah yeah and then
I was telling Lisa that my first TV
credit with a 1996 on Showtime and I get
to a barbecue because Rafa Ralph and
throwing a big barbecue we have a
listener who knows those three guys bro
what's up bro we'll shout out people
Filippo have a barbecue for you at our
my [ __ ] house for me and I think Roxy
and I'm like you're over there you're
Montebello or whatever the [ __ ] it was I
get to barbecue at your Caesar before
you know your mama ha ha ha
Oh Yoshi Thomas yeah work with these
fools and Wow man hey man yeah we were
there I go out that he said some gross
small world man my world huh what that
fool doing now man you know BB is
delivering food with [ __ ] it over and I
watch GrubHub oh my god I hate GrubHub
and he was a the worst bro they somebody
stole my food one time they came my food
came cold one time and they stole my
food it's another time I gave him a
check I getting benefited out okay this
dude must have been hungry never came
with my food yeah man I'm not trying to
bash grab her but I well I I got my the
wrong food showed up 110 i guy was
[ __ ] gone already
I am i competitive phone you know I calm
down and they they took the the charges
out of my card for all that food yeah
yeah I got a break there's not worse if
you're so hungry yeah I'd rather go get
it myself
bro but it Chicago the GrubHub guy who
was a fan of stand-up comedy who I was
so then they see your name and
everything already showed up he saw hey
yeah man go to the show veerraju go with
him he goes yeah man um hey pull you
want to take him to the show
so he brought some food and he drove to
the show went home took a shower came
back with a fat blood what and then
absolutely sure he drove over the back
so I give him four stars dead dog when
she was given five credit by four four
that's it I've done it it's five stars
man you took the dude those four nah man
it's five stars bro those are the wrong
cares different than yeah no this goes
GrubHub yes so that's what I'm be with
is never hug that's not true uber no oh
well they over eat over each that's what
it was
oh yeah yeah sorry I mean pointage book
so yeah so you got the job at 30 system
foods ma I was working the graveyard
over there and I miss dope mails can pay
a lot of money to work their own
graveyard doing nothing pretty much but
um I knew I wanted to do stand-up comedy
man because I used that time there to
write and create man and uh you know it
was it would even though it wasn't busy
over there I saw it as an opportunity
for me to you know work on my material
and get out and I remember man just
being able to get on stage and then get
off and run to work and because you know
I had to be there at 12:00 assumption
you know so I had to show up the club's
early man and but um you know man 23
years later bro still doing it man I'm a
lot funnier cats are calling me a legend
now they were trying to hang around me
to get all the information they can out
of me and asking me how what they got to
do and you know what I tell him what
just do it do it that's it you would we
all we both got to Russell Peters yeah
man I saw Russell the other night matter
of fact Russell's glia wrist
you're not wearing it what's that did he
get your one night and give me a wife
I'm not that good with us yeah but now
Russell's capito Russell's good people
many uh he took me uh let me open for
him a couple of times men and uh he took
me in Edwin San Francisco one time did a
great job up there
we were somebody to generates how you
feel like what's going on here yeah yeah
what do I owe you
oh yeah I figured out my pants yeah but
um other than that man is that you Ray
Last Comic Standing man last robbery
sadly I think the last time I saw you
was doing like cocaine in the liquor
store parking lot
yeah man we were you know it's funny I
want to say that we talked about her in
a podcast with that time that you showed
up to what clearly to do your ear said
that you said Philippe man is cat it
wasn't do cover their to the morning sky
drug your oh yeah bro I told our story
at another podcast and man that's a
better one that's a story that made
after that story people were telling me
Philippe got your pocket podcast yeah so
and as we showed up to my show really
for yeah he had a photo of me at his
house getting dougie points hahaha was
that not the best problem
yes insane row oh no this guy had his
place darkened out we had blackout I
mean when you walk out of that place in
the morning time for a Vegas never like
a damn vampire oh good god it was always
telling people Madame animate everybody
who no matter this is your seat Tommy
the water to you buddy
dummy at that gig at does like we're
walking around his place right before
they had liquid coke hitting all over
the place oh Lord
geez man I used to have a you know I got
tired of sniffing the damned powder so I
I saw somebody they took that cocaine
and he had it like it and it's like
those nasal things used to screw in your
nose
yeah yeah and you had like a little war
he had a little water to it [ __ ] I was
like all right let me try that and I
used to walk around in there like like I
had sinus problems and [ __ ] like okay
open okay
just annoys me
well when I was known when I was using
it he was telling me yeah bro I want to
go to town man I just tackle in my so
cool a nasal spray yeah I get to New
York man but I party okay every to give
a North course like you go around with
those I'm gonna tell you my name too
quick but I thought that would like it
was you know what you're doing could you
like what'd you get a [ __ ] genius
right right I won't do that at home man
yeah man man at a dog hey man you know
what tells us some of the best times of
my career and ever you and I were
partying know what made me laugh one
time man I did a photo I did a bunch of
photos and every photo of the of the
picture had me and different posted like
me laughter II was out like nah we are
sad right we are mad we surprised we
look at crazy
and then everybody writing something but
you wrote the funny with one yeah I seen
all those faces right right man from
this man what else have we been through
and is how your brother saw murder bro I
did actually a damn bro oh man what
happened on this day you know I used to
go to the students man Fagin I see Lola
no he's my coke dealer and my weed
dealer oh yeah though you took me there
once I learn I'm waiting outside you
give me a little bill yeah for $50 yeah
my man I used to go there before you
like this one particular night it was
like March Madness two men stopped over
there man you know you know just before
I went to do my show at the Union and I
was booked to that night and I stopped
there just to hang out and talk and we
were talking about stories man like him
it was man it was my man Jason one other
do to myself and we were just talking
about how we were accident prone us as
kids you know just talking about you
know he I talked about how I used to how
swinging on this swing one time and this
girl was pushing me real hard and I
finally got like you know when you want
to swing in somebody's pushing I mean
not not not like a swing swing but I'm
hanging on this bar it was like a gate
that was split open onto the freeway
yeah so she's like pushing me out
towards the freeway you know and but no
cars would come currently and then she
goes let go and I go all right and I let
go and I'm like my feet are up up up in
the air while my head is back like
towards the ground and I fall back on my
hand and broke my wrist I was telling
that story tone finical yeah man I
remember I was riding a bike and some
lady just cut in front of me he like hit
her and his bike flipped over and he
like when he looked up and his leg was
turned the other way like that like I
was like oh like trying to top each
other's [ __ ] accident to those kids
you know but then it was a knock at the
door bro and man he got up open the door
man and all I saw was this hooded dude
coming through the door with a pistol to
his head and I clearly remember him
saying lay down on me he had that la
accident lay down homey and he put had
to gun up to his head and Jason you know
he was a military that and I guess he
tried to do some type of move you know
to me and it didn't didn't didn't help
him none and I heard the gun go off bro
but before that even happened man um
usually Jason would have you know his
daughter on the weekends and I guess
this kid will go home on that Monday was
a Monday his cable going to his mother
mother that Monday she didn't go home
that night she came out I didn't even
know she was in the back she had came
out when we were talking telling our
stories and stuff and I was all your
daughter's here alright cool
he sends it back in the room caboose you
know he's smoking doing drugs and [ __ ]
and then that's when you know now
understand why he did what he did
because his daughter was there and uh so
you know I immediately got up man the
other dude I don't know what happened to
him I jumped up man and I ran
to his room and I saw his daughter
laying in the bed and I told her to hide
because we were up on the second story
and I didn't want to jump out the window
with her arms because I didn't want to
risk hurting her so I told her she
should hide and I try to open the window
window wouldn't open I tried to break it
with I'm like now I'm in the [ __ ]
movies home so I'm not trying to break
you like that but when wouldn't breaking
then I saw how to unlock it and unlock
it up stepped up in the window growing
there was nothing there to break my fall
but this thin ass [ __ ] twigs of a
tree bro
from the second floor and I said [ __ ] it
I'm going for them and at the same time
looking at the door because it's dude is
coming I heard one shot that was it and
I was going I'm listening for more
because that other dude was in there I
might hear a kill at that pool so anyway
I jumped down on that twig bro and it
man it saved me from her causing damage
to myself and then I started running out
the parking lot and at the same time
looking back at the window cuz I didn't
want that dude coming to the window and
start busting at me so and then there
was a jumped into a parking lot and you
know there's an automatic gate that
slides it slides closed but it was
closed at this particular time and I've
tried to climb over it and as I was
grabbing these spikes at the top of this
gate to climb over one of them gave way
and I fell back and just as I fell back
I saw those two dudes walking slowly
casually as they taking off their
jackets and [ __ ] to the car and they put
they [ __ ] in the trunk and they got in
the car and sat there for a few minutes
and then they took off so I'm like these
dudes are professionals however sorted
to run out huh yeah they they came there
for a reason and so I managed to get
over the gate after they pulled off men
and I went around I ran upstairs bro and
I saw my friend Jason you know it was a
couple people over in with towels and
stuff man and trying to stop him from
bleeding happen he got shot in the head
and man I kinda uh where I left man I
couldn't I couldn't stick around bro I
had to leave and you think something
told me to go back because the
[ __ ] gonna come looking for me
of course you know that I got my
fingerprints all over the place and then
I had to go down and you know do the
whole routine thing with the police man
but Jason was a good do man you know he
just he was a little sloppy with put the
way he handled his business but that was
my experience man you know to this day
man I I don't think I stopped doing
drugs and [ __ ] after that man because I
don't want to be in that atmosphere man
damn man I remember you showed up to
immediately showed up to flight solid I
was there played mattad oh yeah you was
only freaking out like Dawg Dawg you
could just run to my house after that
she happy she but there you were
I used to hang over at your world yeah
you were like you seen a ghost bro yeah
man
it was I never seen like your face -
like you seen well what you saw yeah man
asked that was I was in a hell of an
experience for me bro and I'll tell you
right now man it's one of the reasons
why I don't get involved with you know
that drugs or anything man and uh that's
to smoke weed I go to the dispensary for
that but hopefully nobody ain't gonna
come in here and try to kill about a man
before for a while we were party hard
huh I remember hanging out at your place
a couple of nights lights out TV on
playing games and [ __ ] and doing rails
bro what you used to live that he was
like close to downtown you had a nice
little spot that were looking I'm
boiling stay right there I'm downtown
yeah overlook downtown then to make the
coolest drop but with aluminum foil yeah
I kind of think it was you were going to
[ __ ] it all up and get cut would [ __ ] it
out yo man you know you become crafty
after a while when you pluck and learn
how to do cocaine for so long you ain't
got the utensils and [ __ ] however right
you're she was very stylish to men and
hit the very contagious laugh so exactly
what he did with you man and he's
laughing it's a real like a real genuine
laugh and you do an impression on it cuz
I don't know what is not scary do it man
she I gotta remember it it's gonna let
the only sauce yeah about the time we
stood in line man for [ __ ] uh the
first I write for a lifetime and a man
yeah bro that was something odd
overnight then we it was an open I think
we all I was tired I will you me your
Rodrigo your seat and we always tell the
story of that man we all had cage that
night yeah for somebody holding our spot
right then we get there man we're up all
night
Wow bro that man that was I made it we
made it through wedding a picked I I
actually they aired my might like maybe
a good 15 seconds of my [ __ ] bro didn't
hear me man they gave me a check for
that too also 1200 beans bro you know
what I got that check and I remember the
old Astro to get to get away no no no
the production company the production
company was like hate the union is
asking that we signers check over to him
and at that time I was sleeping in my
car bro I was homeless man and wait a
minute a union wants all of this money
and I don't have any for what you didn't
stand in that line all night like I did
you didn't get me that gig you didn't do
anything to for me to give you this
whole check you know what I mean so I
was like hell no I took that check man
and casted and because I got stuff like
that if you had a good user the team
acquitted before that party like five
years ago I was on MADtv
yes so that team so that one they kept
an apt war when he will get them oh [ __ ]
I was tasked taft-hartley or something
like that yeah so I had like one foot in
one foot out type of thing and I was
like well yeah I don't mind yeah sure
you know I appreciate you know I I
appreciate what the Union does man it's
a unity thing you like you know like the
writers union and I think comics should
have a union as well but you know it's
about doing what's right for people who
work hard out there and making sure
they're getting compensated for their
skills or whatever I'm down for that bro
but man when I'm gonna come hard up bro
and I'm in my car
you know now I got pee in a [ __ ]
bottle I gotta get the bigmouth bottle
you know what I mean cuz yeah you can
yeah water used to be Peter Mickey Sigma
hahaha there you a 6x over you know yeah
EVP little big squads about right gotta
use I use a thermos bro it no dick in
there yeah he needs other properties of
30 tonight
[Laughter]
not with a possibly fee tonight what
time I try to piss in a can cut my dick
all up guys am no I don't try that at
home she yeah you weren't like living in
a car for a while huh yeah man I had a
Honda Civic it was a 9700 city was sure
to walk you're sleepy yeah I was tired I
slept over there too man hi guys I see
I've got all we sit out there bag on
each other for a while
I just wait till I'm bagging on the last
person and he leave iron man I'm done I
but take care see you later I got my car
you went so I'll read somewhere I love
us old trips I am and I did a headlock
bro have you done knows never man it was
rented right uh I don't remember
I don't recall going out with train bro
yeah I don't have you done oh yeah I
know
but yeah I used to work with not us oh
but it was MWR I did a lot of shows for
those guys men over in the Middle East
but at that time it was Iraq Kuwait
Afghanistan I've also been to Japan and
Germany and just recently I was over in
the Mediterranean bro you know Greece
Jordan man usually she wouldn't come
back from the Mediterranean manual way
to a better training white pads
ODI yeah yeah it was like a Muslim hey
man those pants are comfortable sheets
they look like she's a man do I get
comfortable they're like over there were
wide open like MC Hammer pants and I am
a CUFI and [ __ ] yeah you know man if I
had to choose I don't I don't have a
religion right now I don't follow it
really I think all religions are more
like a cult but if I had to choose it
would be Islam and I think they're more
timorous [ __ ] together bro you know what
I mean although I like the fact that
you're able to have more than one wife
how about you sleeping would you like to
have more than one wife yeah I'll prove
it if your wife approve she would have
to be the first one though you know she
can t control all the other four beige I
can hold more men should be that the
main one and I don't think I don't think
Latin women would tolerate that hell naw
man you stuck it into a fight every
night yeah my just five latino women
saying Hyundai watch where you going
where you going take me with you buy you
something
how come you haven't done done anything
military runs I don't know if I go back
there but they have a green card what
whoa you gonna mark oil Tony you get it
I never been asked are you good now can
you try I'm good to tell me where
anywhere now I was Harbor that you know
Donald Trump you know he's he's gonna
make it tough for you I'm good to go now
brush after 2005 man time when I did the
the young comedians at the motel company
anymore so that means from 2005 right
five years Pat no after no Union gigs
Wow I will do premium blend right hmm
and Montreal Comedy fur to do the pain
nothing you know the JP field trip
planner here shows so I'm with an agent
now right so I get premium blend right
and I'm broke dog I got no money and I'm
think I'm gonna keep the check without
even ask you they took that [ __ ]
do you yeah Mike I was so sad you have
to sign it over to yeah but didn't know
but I was just happy you're not going to
get it and didn't get it but I'll mouth
like what and remember I'm Joe right he
pulled a fit bro Adam over there at the
[ __ ] um the Just for Laughs team with
Bob summers and Kevin Hart that yeah
yeah yeah he wanted to check what
they're they don't want to give it to
him he was all pissed off
I can not take a duel that Wow
so they just took your [ __ ] like that
bro wow that's gotta be of weird that's
that sucks man it's just a jack it's
like strong-arm robbery you know what I
mean just but what can you do man you
know I mean I'm sure you good with the
Union now oh yeah I'm good man I got my
teeth fixed called oak music oh snap yo
oh man yes they're ready bro look at
Joey man everything bull man hands over
here that's gonna be replaced I said
awesome oh yeah she got a beautiful
round look at that smile bro I'm good to
me I got ya
awesome and I remember man we're doing
we're doing we're partying and I'm had a
chick at the time and then she was
sleeping and we just kept party bro man
and I can't believe I'm out like good
[ __ ]
then I whatever I showed up to peanut
house with a name huh PJ PJ how can the
PJ cells do it was Holly I believe his
house wait which one which house was
this wasn't the one on Fairfax or what
an orange or is all the little room the
little little room yeah bout Fairfax I'm
fair price yeah on Fairfax oh yeah no no
that was a house there's an apartment on
orange at Santa Monica
oh yeah I know it how she talked about
yeah it was a little crooked do da de
Vai oh my god bro that [ __ ] man
I was there for three days straight yeah
and I'm PJ had to go to the conference
to at work and I just followed him to
wait for him but a bar getting [ __ ] up
you with the wrong person
oh sorry Jody insomnia goes we with here
I'm here with PJ in your seat you're the
man
PJ is he is the marathon uh cokehead oh
one yeah we used to stay on Normandie
like just north of sunset you know one
it was a studio okay all you guys it was
it was KD
afraid
interesting pieces do so man it's like
that's where my biggest yay got killed
in Vegas Bally's
it was PJ Davey Wester myself and Kate
Katie and we were in this one little
small [ __ ] and Katie was that Dougie
points party - yeah oh yeah oh yeah
Davey didn't hang out with us much like
that but it was us three really the most
who was just like going at it but uh we
were coke [ __ ]
yeah we this one particular night man
after doing so much [ __ ] coke man I
was doing I was the only one who could
probably fall asleep after Coco
out of the bunch I thought that how you
enjoyed air could do that but you know
just go get it but we don't have
something like it I'm gone my rest is
more important think I look so young
right now fighting a cocaine they go to
sleep [ __ ] but anyway so this one night
I hope I wake up and TVs blaring away
lights on
Cady's knocked out Davey's knocked out
but PJ was sleeping on a fruit on him
that was empty
I'm like Dan where the hell is he hit
well maybe you went out got a prostitute
a song you know but they were all down
in area I said when I are going to use a
bass might get up off the floor and go
in the bathroom I'm sitting over the
toilet door my thing and out of nowhere
PJ steps out from the shower only what
though just like one swoop bro
Karen curtain go back for he just goes
right out jumps on a car on this futon
I'm like what the hell was you doing in
there man I think it wasn't it
[ __ ] it was so weird girl creepy
right yeah damn that was weird
PJ lives in Jersey now he moved and yeah
he helps the poor yeah no go yeah gotta
believe in something can't believe it
Coco your whole life who you it I'm
nobody man hey you're both so
independent bro yeah you and I both man
I don't um don't care too much about it
if I ever get to that that tax bracket I
might go for conservative broke you know
they keep their money yeah we don't have
the money right I want to keep your
[ __ ] social social
benefits like free health care Alma care
right you know I'll vote for someone if
they saying hey let's put it in the rent
increase I'll vote for you you know
reason why rent should be going on bro
and [ __ ] is ridiculous man I know my
gotta go to a play that read control
like where I live anymore old people the
day but they still it still goes up
doesn't it like if I was still going up
like 3% of 10 yes I - actually putting a
dent in my pocket I remember man um when
you were I guess you were homeless at
the time mmm but didn't know could you
would you're sure with Japanese [ __ ]
like wow I want to be homeless I feel
lonely from home a USO tour I guess yet
the water hahaha
I thought you were loud but to get that
one home Allah was louder bro from New
York oh my friend Dante he's cool yeah
so doctor from Hollywood no no no not
that doctor dark-skinned ooh yeah you
were had yeah yeah yeah yeah Dante I
know you funny man
he should be a comment yeah he's a he's
a he's a nurse assistant he's love
doctor a nurse assistant or some doctor
I don't know what they call those people
I go to school the nursing school to
become a efficient a physician as he
draws blood yeah he draws blood and
check your pulse in your temperature but
I know you don't really well in New York
- he's the drink I used to drink that
adios [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] Oh God
that's uh I never see him watch it watch
it hey Walker Yoda's well clearly
drinking Windex look like Windex bro man
that [ __ ] man [ __ ] that I knew that the
minute should probably give a person
diabetes but I especially a black person
I ain't trying to drink that [ __ ] I'm
not much of a drinker man but I smoked
weed and a lot of cocaine back on Monday
a lot of party animals back that off and
I always feel like if you put you if
you're partying like that now he's gonna
die
yeah well you know for a Freddy Soto man
he you're with him right
I wasn't no I was actually overseas when
passed away oh yeah and uh when I got
the news but I never party with him no I
I haven't either I haven't partied with
Freddie but Freddie actually I'm lying
probably probably did a couple of bumps
in the back of the comedy store once but
he is the one who got me my showcase
with Mitzi Konami story Emma
yeah Mantha was for him grow up I
probably would've never made it through
you know but my first initial showcase
was through him but I didn't get passed
but I was I was able to you know get
more after that and I remember the last
showcase I got before I got passed I was
standing in the back of the comedy store
and Mitzi I came that came in and I was
like you know what I'm going to accent
see if I can showcase I was talking to
the two doors in the back covered to the
door guy in the back in the parking lot
guy and they hate those anything I can't
remember who they were but they were
hating they were like nah man you don't
want to go near miss with Mickey man I
don't people mess with her in the middle
of showcases [ __ ] man shut up and I went
you know what she sat right like a chair
right by the door now and I went in I
kneeled down beside her I was like hey
Mitzi and she looked over to me I could
see unless you you know face at that
time she was kind of little she was
still competent but she cheats she knew
I wasn't but she's like Nancy can I kind
of showcase for you if you're gonna fall
out and she was like okay and showing up
bro no less than five minutes later
broad when I was on the back and the
cover booth guy that tide came in I was
like hey Mitch he wants you to come and
showcase and bro I tell you man when I
went up there man I gave it my all bro
and sure enough she told me right there
in their iPad you passed and I was so
happy man that was the best time of my
life over there oh your rings light up
to - right
yeah my name up on the wall yeah no it
was it meant something then bro cause
you use you showcase I mean I had to
show kids at least eight times me to you
know to me and now these cats bro
thankee I don't know it's different now
man I'm not trying to talk down on them
or anything like that but bein they
didn't work for it like like we had to
work for to get password away now
um I don't think that you know what I it
seemed like it's like that you wanna me
it seems like it because I was there man
for a while Adams cat state they may
have been there but they never showcase
but then when they get that showcasing
the opportunity then they get past you
know it's like I'm nowadays they'll make
you a regular Jessica you know Joe Rogan
and he's a monster yeah just get a
monster to who you know bill yeah man
but um I mean hats off to those guys
over there Tommy stores taking a
household where every room sold out
every room is always busy now you know
it's vice versa what the laugh actor
used to be oh ha ha ha ha ah ha ha ha ha
they were busy one point he'll mother
brother were busy we know though when it
was a cafe okay
Oh down the street whenever down this
yeah yeah yeah well you know I have my
opinions about the ha I'm always on the
fence with those guys but nonetheless
man you know business is business
you know and you got to do whatever you
can to survive you know that's what it's
about these days man you got shows
coming up no no I'm happy being on I'm
actually what I'm doing Felipe is I'm
I'm writing a screenplay man I'm in the
middle of writing it bro and I finally
got around to you know getting up off my
ass and stop procrastinating huh
you know and putting forth the effort
and putting the screenplay together I'm
pretty proud of myself at this point
because you know I've mapped it out and
I got the story line down I'm putting
down the dialogue and my characters all
developed and stuff and you know doing a
lot of reading and watching movies and
stuff and just trying to make sure I got
all the pieces in the right place man
you know what I mean so I feel good
about it I feel really good about it and
I don't expect much from it but I just
want to make sure it's a great story you
know a little bit about um you know just
try to keep it brief it's basically
about a kid who of course who's who who
was put in the position to take on a job
that he has no
training for basically a fish out of
water situation but he takes on this job
to get a girl and at the same time the
girl's father who owns the businesses
you know he has a gambling problem
keep that song cockfights you know and
he loses his business to a [ __ ] fighting
a [ __ ] fight and unbeknownst to his
family you know he has to try to save it
before you know the peso's come and take
it from her so I kind of got a nice
little spin on it so to do he promised a
girl that he helped save the business
and I don't want to give away judge
because it's uh I think it's a unique I
deal about it but the typical structure
for movies and you know the the
coming-of-age
fish-out-of-water type thing you know
it's uh it's in an in an if I could just
say the slug line would be you know to
save a single flowers is to save the
world
oh pretty much a zone um but in that you
know just want to keep out the wraps you
seem a lot of [ __ ] home man tell us
about that time so we're listening about
that time you told me you were standing
outside a comet or smoking a joint
somebody jumps off the building
damn bro uh yeah damn I can't believe
you remember this stuff man
I know buddy oh man you know whatever
way you get will you will you have a
friend you know they tell you so you
know you don't forget that you know with
me uh Thomas Ward hollering war great
he's in town nations bring him on more
man Thomas Ward man um we were sitting
at the comedy store you know like you
know it was called a what was it called
it is and as now but it's called the
Hyatt so high yeah and you know how I
said if they had the balconies and you
know up there but this guy this one
particular day I was uh who's sitting up
right there in the front on the patio
and Thomas war I was actually I actually
had my back towards da2 Hyatt and Thomas
Ward was facing me as I was sitting up
on the counter of it the rail or
whatever and Thomas Cole what the [ __ ]
was that
and I already hit the ground like smack
like it was a piece of metal or
something I hit the ground like
back and I turned around I saw this body
laying in the driveway of the high-end
row immediately I jumped off man I ran
over there and was this white boy just
sprawled out on the ground and I just
soon as I got there bro I heard him take
his last breath like damn and that was
it
he fell from the fourth floor
they said this dude was drunk or
something he tried to sit up on the
balcony and fell off to his death from
damn to his death so then I lived
through the bars
Emin and they just recently had somebody
got shot over at the Comedy Store - this
was like last year I think did you hear
about that once um cuz I won't go to
another gunshot on my damn and I was
weird
well you know what here's what a lot of
people don't know the kid who got shot
his family reached out to me through
Instagram so we were I was sitting in
the back you were there I was there at
night I was sitting in the back there's
a back bar for the comics and then Jess
- whatever and you know it's crowded
music playing and we hear pop pop pop
pop pop you know and the bartender goes
you know that was just firecrackers the
devil's guns you know people be going
crazy [ __ ] then a few minutes later
piano guy Jeff comes in the back hey
somebody just got shot out in the front
and everybody rush off the damn place
and I go out and of course me my nosy
ass always like to look at dead body in
the [ __ ] go up there but I'm coming from
the parking lot and I'm looking over and
I see the kid stretched out in front of
the in front in front of the front door
bro I mean literally like in front of
the front door this guy was taken out
packed house bro that bar that patio was
packed and I see this kid so I thought
about taking a picture up but I didn't
do it out of respect you know what I
mean
but I should have because that's just
the way it is these days you know what I
mean and but I took a picture of them
carry them into the ambulance and I
posted it up on Instagram I took a
picture of like people no cops
single filing people out of the parking
lot you know making sure everybody's
and whatever I guess it's protocol for
them - I took a try that and I posted up
on Instagram then next thing you know
I'll get a I get a message from his aunt
from New York and she was like you know
what's going on over there I'm his on
you know and what happened and I tried
to explain to her you know as much as
possible you know what I what I knew and
I told her you know he said that some
guy just out of nowhere came up and just
opened fire on him I said he was there
with like three other dudes one was in a
wheelchair
they were staying in a hotel next door
and they had left him there all three of
those do went over to the hotel that's
when he got shot and then they came back
so it's kind of weird how that happened
for them to just leave him like that
yeah especially going to wheelchair yeah
I could've waited they were exactly were
you going will you won't roll off to so
they huh so they said this guy man he
just stood right there to edge it at the
edge of the entrance and just opened
fire on a man and all those shots hit
him you go there there's no bullets in
the glass door you notice a glass door
you know no bullets in the wall you know
who else was standing there sandy brown
damn you know she was a red bro she was
all right man she she'd have a karate on
lumbered on no yeah yo she was standing
right there on the stairs man and she
saw this dude getting laid out bro hey
bro never has too bad have been one of
the terrifying moments ever bro but must
turn down other steady bro had a spot
yeah she'd have spotted night 84 haha
used to ha yeah man she let's get around
young girl sandy bro yeah no panties
blue she's about my complexion
yeah but her yeah man yeah man I
remember Bob Weir Walker yo T's man you
our stage then you would like to having
a tough time I was kid I never ever
thought there
Ronnie Perry walks in with Katt Williams
and you like yo who invited the [ __ ]
ha ha ha ha crowd lasted up until then I
never notice that cat everybody pay with
that sword
ok are short I really carry the happen
everybody look at it it's funny
may you remember a lot of [ __ ] I can't
remember anything it was most that good
stuff I remember one time and I had to
take a [ __ ] at wild coyotes after doing
the [ __ ] line
you know you do cocaine so much you got
the [ __ ] runs just go with bad stuff
some [ __ ] baby laxatives associate man I
was driving over there and I had I was
holding it in the car
and when I finally got it I only think I
parked my car right I just bailed out
and ran into the bathroom bro took a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and the [ __ ] was mixed with
blood I was like I'm dying down your
hemorrhages like that some [ __ ] bell go
get the ROI right I don't think it was
Royce it was probably could have been
cancer I'd have went for the first time
I play years ago I was dying but I'm
gonna die you had hemorrhoids yeah it
was at that bad I didn't know what it
was at first I was constipated
then I just focused on pushing like our
blood and almost broke soccer today
what's our dr. Mamphela did you feel it
right nah it's like my net just hurt
like hell man crying like a [ __ ] yeah
what's up fool what can people follow
you white on Instagram um hi or see or
just type in your C Thomas all my
information will come up y ou urs ie
whatever whatever whatever happened to
that [ __ ] comedy DVD with Dan the
streets you know what we used to your
daughter I gotta tell you I looked at
that the other day bro I was watching
that the area and they were aired up ah
hold
I think they aired it in Somalia
I think it's a lot I think the Pirates
are loving it over it to top five comedy
special on a submarine man though that
was a great concept to brown surprised I
didn't go that far I think I would
probably do well now though the other
side of this kind of to write a
beginning here my son yeah Billy yeah
he's in New York now he's rapping now
how does he know yeah you ready ready
for me to age you right now yeah it's
gonna be older my son no Joseph
it's about to be 20 son my son's 31 oh
wow
my son he'll be 32 yeah 30 32 clear Adam
in the high school I got I got a I got a
huh you hit him in high school also when
I was in high school yeah you know I had
him when I was 18 oh no I am finish high
school
I mean yous about high school man
[ __ ] man I don't know man
right now I regret that I didn't finish
school either I do something I wanna
watch good funny College mirrors yeah
yeah I grotty did you go back to school
or when I see a smart comic up on stage
articulating and using [ __ ]
phenomenal words and [ __ ] on my [ __ ]
always say [ __ ] up he tells do the
rules I could do
hahahahaha forget booed off days I wish
I guess right ha ha ha
my guess because I wouldn't do it like
every eye will open up for him some more
Bruce Bruce and I didn't realize I won't
go up there and start doing my stand-up
without greeting nobody right they don't
like that [ __ ] oh yeah gotta come up
applause you got a yeah you Charlie
Murphy told me this bro he said you got
to go up and you got a you know I'm a
don't feel good yeah or compliment them
yes something like that to break the ice
you gotta hide a trick I was like wow so
I was up the talk to my stand-up right
away you know
don't laugh but it wasn't to like well
this it was oh the middle side of this
side and then I go up there then I
started laughing right and it was all
started Mike Epps because I had a I had
a Charlie Murphy book that I took from a
comedy club and one of the work I had a
story about about um
Charlie Murphy doing stand-up comedy I
was bombing a lot and then you thought
bombing real hard you know what I
suddenly started opening up for my cabs
he started bombing and then I was
telling my cabs that he wrote about you
on his book about bombing and you gave
him good advice and Maiev said oh yeah
man
it is Def Jam crowd man would be dying
up there he was telling me how bad
Charlie Murphy will do it because I'm
here and I sort of know man he did
particularly bad in Cleveland because he
had did an interview where he said he
was abroad of comedy mmm he just started
doing comedy last year we were really
killing it and doing theatres mmm but
the crowd heard about the man they were
booing him wrong
no I got him I kept story oh yeah I used
to work for a company called lazer
Pacific which is post-production and
Mike Epps project came career I worked
in a library where all the elements came
in you know everybody's material and it
was film tapes or whatever well his
stuff was on like I was on a DVR high or
something like that cameraman but I was
able to uh I saw when he came in and I
saw Mike Epps one day at the store
somewhere and I said hey Mike I said
your project came through my job he goes
what is the those were you working I
said we're got ladies of Pacific so okay
so my ship and not get out on the street
I can see their favorite nah man I'm
gonna do that to you bro I wouldn't do
that
so long story short next day I get any
[ __ ] work they pulled me in the
office bro this fool try to get me fired
man trying to get man I had to feed my
[ __ ] kids
man what this nature anyway man put that
[ __ ] I'll do like so play told why I
should man
what's up you know who Thomas in the
house yo man once again man thanks for
having me
thanks for having a growth I'll stick to
all this crazy [ __ ] like me and you
George Perez bro running around with
this ladies card for three days
when we had the bug
do you mean hahaha you and I slept in
his and it is out couch in the you in
the [ __ ] go ride oh god man no sleep
till Brooklyn ha ha ha ha your CD album
oh my god jeez man how are you how are
you able to like store all this [ __ ] I
guess you're a prize bro I just hoped
from Louie the 13 broke pre-roll what is
this you know some pre rows bro they
give it to you hash and it's all it's
all [ __ ] shake that's the real [ __ ]
brother that was George that to put
Tupac smoke before the shot of mance
this [ __ ] that's gonna be butt naked in
a chicken coop hell yeah brother kind of
[ __ ] that's a joint that Trenton Stewart
locked himself up in his trunk
nice to join he smoked and now he's a
Christian Bible toting right now sorry
blog ha ha ha ha I'm talking about on to
my parents Tim yeah cherish is that we
said 10 you out here until we call them
head head yeah head man
head yeah man I saw him out the other
day our head Shan greedy daddy try to
convert me to no man I'm not my daughter
bro come on brother was your fault your
see Thomas man Felipe Esparza level up
later it's Twitter um st. a man just
google my name your see while you are as
I eat very unique name and yeah man
somebody tried to steal my [ __ ] though
they try to make it into a onesie yeah
try to name the onesie after my name bro
nah I'm thinking about serving a
cease-and-desist
I'm sure bro they sent me one curly
senior onesie ha ha ha ha they save you
a seat to work on a cease-and-desist in
the system - what for shirt war so fool
for that pressure later yeah for that
one wow we out of here man right yeah
you're gonna say goodbye later man